as Tom Cruise kept in touch since then
yeah yeah he gives me a cake every
Christmas it's as we call it the cruise
cake at my house it's just this coconut
cake it's the best coconut cake I've
ever had in my life
it's from downes bakery in the valley so
sorry everybody it's really good and
yeah we get it every every Christmas
we're like all our fans like cruise
cakes it's like a major thing that's a
lovely thing yeah I guess that's a kind
of traditions actors give each other
gifts so Chris what did you get Jessica
at the end of the huntsmen yeah where'd
you get me Chris well we have about what
did you give me at the start of it gave
you I gave Chris a candle from little
boa in which you can actually have the
person's name on the label I didn't
realize so I gave it back yeah
[Laughter]
you're never getting refine our started
to smell funny so what lint her the camp
and I tell you it was like no Chris you
can't give me the gift I gave you anyway
doesn't matter block fighting freely
lovely things at the end of episodes he
does not know no he does not he doesn't
buy me anything
oh these now he's earning all that top
gear money where's my gift
so essentially Tom Cruise is ruining it
for everyone yes he needs to cancel that
case only gives presence on rap but
continuously for years are 8 years after
see that's impressive isn't present I've
never done that except for my parents
[Music]
but they are great
[Applause]
you